Okay. Let's add something new to our URLs,
called a Query parameter--
also known as GET parameters--
and we'll talk about this name shortly,
when we start talking about http.
Here is an example:
We've got our normal URL--
or the type of the simple URL we just discussed--
with a simple Path, /foo,
and we've added, to the end of this, ?p=1.
And this adds an extra parameter, whose name is "p" and whose value is "1".
The format of the Query parameter looks like this:
You've got "Name = value"
or in this case, "p=1".
And the value can be just about anything,
but it's good not to use question marks and other URL characters;
although you could, if you really wanted.
We can make this a little bit more complicated, by adding more Query parameters.
Let's do that--we've added a second Query parameter.
The first Query parameter is separated from the URL,
using a question mark.
All the following parameters are separated from each other,
using ampersands.
The first one gets a question mark, the next one gets an ampersand.
In this case, the new parameter is "q" and it equals the string, "neat".
So we have these Query parameters--what are they for?
They're for--basically, when you make a request for this Path,
this is extra information the Server gets.
And there's all sorts of things you can do with this.
If this is a Web application, doing fancy things,
these parameters might mean something.
It can affect caching--
because, technically, it changes the entire URL.
So there are all sorts of handy uses,
that we'll discuss later in the class,
for what these Query parameters can do.
But they're separate from the Path--
but they are included in part of the whole URL
that the Servers use when you make a request.
In the following URL, what is the value of the z parameter?
Here is your URL.